outriders is a game that isn't defined
by big new ideas
but a variety of familiar elements mixed
together in experimental ways
it's a role-playing game with loot
shooter elements it's a serious dark
sci-fi story with a big dose of
goofiness and humor
it's a cover shooter that demands you
rush out and smash enemies with
ludicrous superpowers
whether this mixture works for you will
determine how much you'll enjoy it
[Music]
though outriders looks like a loot
shooter live game
it's actually much more mass effect 3
than destiny 2.
like in mass effect rpg progression and
cover shooting are much more important
than chasing the next new gun
outriders is a cover shooter rpg with a
hearty dose of gear progression
leaning heavily into an epic story told
with tons of dialogue cut scenes and
collectible lore
developer people can fly draws a lot
from its past work on the gears of war
series
rifle-toting enemies take fortified
positions to unload on you at a distance
backed up by shotgunners that try to
close the gap armored troops with chain
guns plotting in the open
and cleaver wielding sprinters who
charge straight at your face to drive
you out of cover
the core of outriders is shooting and
you'll have a mess of guns at your
disposal
though you can only have two main
weapons and a sidearm equipped at any
given time
you'll have lots of options thanks to
loot shooter half of the outrider's
formula
that means you can pair a sniper rifle
with a shotgun or assault rifles with
smgs and since you're constantly
searching for weapons with better stats
you'll cycle through a lot of different
loadouts in a short amount of time
what makes these guns especially fun are
the myriad different properties and
status effects they can have
like dispensing poison blowing enemies
up freezing people solid
and so on recalling gears of war again
outrider shooting reliably feels good
but finding synergies between your
weapon's weird properties
is a lot of what makes the shooting part
of the game rewarding
things get a bit weirder as outriders
merges space superpowers with its cover
shooter core
you could choose from one of four
character classes early in the game
devastator trickster pyromancer or
technomancer
these each have the general roles of
tank rogue
damage focused mage and debuff focus
mage the devastator uses gravity attacks
for close range kills
the trickster teleports around to get
the drop on enemies
the pyromancer is a mid-range
fireflinger and the technomancer can
summon turrets and rockets
that also poison or slow targets each
class has a different way of
replenishing health through combat
generally by focusing on their specific
strengths the devastator for instance
heals you for every close range kill
encouraging you to get in close to
enemies to hit them with powers like a
small earthquake
combat becomes a constant calculus
between when to cut the distance and
take down an enemy
and when to take cover bide your time
and protect yourself
that combination can be a bit confusing
and as a result
combat is a place where outriders can
both sprint and stumble
you're playing a shooter where you use
cover to keep yourself alive
but you're encouraged to leave cover to
keep yourself alive
that push and pull of avoiding incoming
damage and taking the fight to the enemy
means that you constantly have to be
managing the battlefield
as well as your ability cooldown timers
if you jump out of cover and go wild
with all your powers on an approaching
enemy
you leave yourself exposed for all their
friends and quickly find yourself cut
down by incoming fire
that means that having an earthquake
ready to stun incoming fighters
is essential to saving your life since
it allows you to grab kills
while keeping your head down similarly
abilities like the trickster's teleport
which instantly puts you behind enemies
who are in cover are just as useful for
dramatically repositioning yourself
across the battlefield
as they are for eliminating foes but you
can rarely just go all out with your
guns and abilities you really have to
think about where you are
where your enemies are and how you can
best eliminate them without exposing
yourself
it can feel unintuitive for a while but
when you do find the balance between
using your powers
healing yourself and staying out of fire
outriders can create some pitched
frantic battles that use cover just
enough to give you a second to breathe
without nailing your shoulder to a
single chest high wall
and leaving you there for minutes on end
but there are also times when you'll
find yourself surrounded or cut off
trapped between enemies unable to kill
anything fast enough
or escape the onslaught to save yourself
sometimes a situation will just feel
unwinnable
but luckily outriders generally sets you
back only a bit when you die
so you can re-enter a fight quickly and
try a new approach
facing tougher altered enemies who have
power similar to yours
can result in battles of attrition where
you have to cheese the situation
by scurrying out of the arena so enemies
don't all chase you down at once
sometimes even careful management of
powers cover
and your spacing on the battlefield
aren't enough to save you
and it's these moments when outriders
can get frustrating because it doesn't
feel like you're losing for lack of
skill there are ways to deal with that
issue
outriders is largely pretty open and has
liberal fast travel
so you can bail on a mission and go do
side quests to grab rewards that can
boost your gear and character
the difficulty of enemies is also
determined by your overall world
tier level which rises as you earn
experience points
alongside your character level world
tier also determines loot drops
so there is an incentive to keep it on
the highest level you can
but if you're in a particularly annoying
fight you could always back it down a
touch to keep yourself from stalling
the world tier is a smart solution to
the difficulty problem
and since it can be adjusted anytime it
gives you a lot of freedom to avoid
frustration at key moments
while the combat can be tough to wrap
your head around at first the frenetic
balancing act has created some heart
pounding moments
more fun and intense battles than
annoying ones you can also play out
riders in co-op which really elevates
how frantic and wild combat can become
having multiple super powered players
working together makes for a bombastic
sensory overloading combat experience
outriders is best experienced with
friends and other players
co-op continually highlights the game's
best features
and encourages you to think creatively
about combining powers
guns battlefield control and teamwork
unfortunately playing together has been
tough since out writer's launch
cross play between consoles and pc is
currently disabled
and some players have complained of
server connection issues while i didn't
encounter any connection problems while
i played solo on pc
i did have repeated crashes when
connecting with friends
and trying to play together on console
the server issues are even worse
with lengthy wait times when loading
into the game and unexpected disconnects
when playing
those technical issues will likely get
cleaned up over time
but right now it's frustrating that the
game's always online nature
means even those playing in single
player are stuck dealing with some of
the problems
people can fly has said it's working to
improve the experience
but so far the most frustrating thing
about the game has been those times when
i crashed to desktop
when trying to play with friends when it
comes to its narrative
i enjoyed outrider's lengthy story
although it winds up being more
disjointed than what was implied in the
first half or so
people can fly has obviously put a lot
of time and thought into the game's lore
and there's a lot of interesting writing
to be found in the journal entries and
side quests
enoch the planet where outriders takes
place was meant to be an idyllic new
world for the remnants of humanity to
colonize
instead it's a war-torn hellscape where
the last vestiges of the human race are
ripping each other apart
the misery and torment of the situation
is exacerbated by the altered
like your character who have gained
godlike powers
unfortunately the longer it goes on the
less outriders mixes
its intense topics and blockbuster-like
humor
things get dark as time goes on but the
road trip style story
abandons examining how to handle being a
human-turned god
and instead looks into atrocities
related to scientific ethics
and colonialism in the end it feels like
outriders shift subjects a few times
leaving a lot of the threads hanging and
without bringing many to a satisfying
conclusion
but the moments where outriders is
taking daring swings
at mixing disparate elements are when
it's at its best
the game is surprisingly deft at
combining things that
shouldn't work together to make
something new and fun especially when
you've got friends with you
and put the time in to really understand
the game's systems
outriders rewards you with epic battle
moments and a sprawling scope
it left me wanting to continue venturing
out into the wilds of enoch
to see what i might find there and to
smash whatever it was
with seismic earthquake magic
[Music]
you